obviously is a tornado because you can
see it touching the ground there
doesn't it looks like a rope tornado at
this point we get those big widespread
ones
this one's more of a thinner one however
you can see there is obviously some
in the background there we do have some
homes there we're checking on any
tornado watches or warnings at this
point
denver i am seeing some some pops
pop-up storms there right around denver
at this hour i'm looking right now at my
radar of course we want to stay on that
picture there
incredible shot from our camera here
looking at this and of course it is a
tornado this is not a funnel cloud
it is touching the ground i'm looking to
see if i see a debris cloud that's when
it actually picks up debris
picks it up and spins it around the
cloud this is what we call a rope
tornado it's more of a thinner variety
if we get those big thick ones which we
don't want those can be
ef4s ef5s i'm not saying that's what it
is right now because we cannot determine
what it is the strength of it until we
see the damage that is done
of course it looks like it may be also
in an
urban area where you could see the homes
there too so
of course the meteorologists they're
very experienced in denver probably told
everybody go the lowest level their
homes
their basements as they should because
right now this
is a tornado that is touching the ground
and it looks like it is causing some
damage we'll have more updates on that
coming up